هنا في قريه البصالح بمنطقه اليوسفيه جنوب
بغداد يقع منزل التوام السيامي عمر وعلي
الذين اجريت لهما عمليه جراحيه استغرقت 11
ساعه حبس معها سكان القريه انفسهم وهم
يتابعون اولا باول تفاصيل العمليه التي
اجريت في مستشفى الملك عبد الله التخصصي
للاطفال في السعوديه
لكن فقط مدى الحياه بس الحمد لله والشكر
وفضل الله وفضل الفريق الطبي اللي تم هذه
العمليه بنجاح وان شاء الله صارت لهم حياه
جديده
اكثر من ثمانيه اشهر من بعد ولادتهما
قضاها هذا التوام السيامي هنا قبل نقلهما
الى الرياض لاجراء واحده من اكثر العمليات
تعقيدا لفصل التوائم في العالم
الطبي على مساعدتهم ان اللي هم ساهم
باخراج همم
من العراق
السيامي علي وعادتهم الى الحياه من جديد
قريه التي تنتظر بفارغ الصبري عوده التوام
السيامي عمر وعلي من المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بعد نجاح عمليه فصلهما ومنحهما
حياه جديده من اليوسفيه جنوب بغداد منتظر
رشيد العربيه